imaginem dentro de um carro grande
bonito confortável inovador um carro tão
inovadora
você está sentado atrás olha pra frente
e ele não tem nada não tem motorista
porque aquele carro autônomo self iguais
e aí está lá dentro daquele carro
fazendo o que você quiser ou basicamente
olho no celular
quer tudo você pode fazer dentro de um
carro e depois de duas horas e quarenta
pessoas gastam nossas cidades hoje você
tira um pouco da tela
naquela levantadinha méxico pescoço
nénão assaltada quando você faz isso
você olha pra fora
quando se olha para fora seria um
movimento acontecendo você vê pessoas
passando de bicicleta a pé ou até de
patinete elétrico que talvez você não
perceba seu olhar é que muitas daquelas
pessoas está fazendo o mesmo trajeto que
você só que gastando metade do seu tempo
e agora vão poder fazer o que elas
quiserem
só que sem estar presas dentro daquele
automóvel gastar duas horas e quarenta
como vê todos os dias não aconteceu de
uma hora pra outra
isso é decorrência de um movimento
histórico das nossas cidades nossas
cidades nasceram naquela velha região
central daquela pracinha daquela igreja
que a gente ainda vê em algumas cidades
do interior ea partir dali ela foi
crescendo e se expandindo as pessoas
foram morar no cada vez mais longe
daquele centro
porém boa parte das nossas atividades
ainda acontece naquela velha região
então a diferença que a gente chama hoje
daquele centro urbano daquela região que
a gente vai todos os dias trabalhar
estudar e realizar nossas atividades ea
única forma que a gente encontrou de
conectar as pessoas que estão morando
cada vez mais longe daquelas está aquela
cidade da região central foi investindo
em um objeto de uma tonelada que leva em
média um ponto duas vezes em ponta das
pessoas por vez ou seja investimos tudo
para que o carro pudesse fluir melhor
e qual o resultado disso onde chegamos
com esse investimento e um esgotamento
total desse modelo
mas o pior é quando a gente começa a
olhar um pouco mais a fundo esses
números hoje 7 em cada 10 pessoas se
locomovem através de um meio de
transporte que não o carro mas 80% da
nossa infraestrutura viária é destinada
para quem para os automóveis
ou seja temos 20% a nossa infraestrutura
para ciclovias ciclofaixas faixas de
ônibus corredores de brt estações de
trem estações de metrô 20% da nossa
infraestrutura servindo 70% dos nossos
deslocamentos e é por isso que hoje tem
tão pouca liberdade de ir e vir no nosso
dia a dia
se parar para pensar mas a gente tem
liberdade para muito mais coisas do que
a gente tinha há 20 anos atrás mais
liberdade do que a gente quer pedir pra
comer que música a gente quer ouvir ou
até com que o que vamos trabalhar
mas essa mesma liberdade a gente não tem
para se locomover para ir ao trabalho
para a universidade ou para ir à escola
e é justamente isso que eu tenho me
dedicado tanto nos últimos nove anos
poder pensar soluções não para os 30%
que se locomove de carro todos os dias
mas para todos
um exemplo disso é o nosso projeto aqui
o bike rio as laranjinhas se a gente
pegar esse projeto
mais da metade das pessoas que usam a
bicicleta todos os dias nesse projeto
não moram na região central onde o
projeto foi instalado justamente o
contrário
são pessoas que vêm de regiões afastadas
da cidade trem metrô ônibus descem aqui
na central do brasil e conectam com a
bicicleta para chegar no seu destino
final
repensar a forma que a gente se locomove
através da integração modal conectando
transporte de massa com soluções de
micro mobilidade é uma das formas que a
gente tem para poder melhorar o nosso
ele vir para poder melhorar nosso
deslocamento diário
eu tive essa experiência quando podiam
morar fora e passei seis meses só usando
a bicicleta todos os dias e aquilo me
garantiu todo o meu deslocamento toda a
minha liberdade nem daquela cidade
hoje somos 500 pessoas aqui no vitória
eu queria deixar uma pequena reflexão
cidade teremos uma cidade onde todos
aqui andamos de carros autônomos por aí
uma cidade que garanta mais tempo para a
nossa população e ao mesmo tempo seja
uma cidade mais leve econômica e
compartilhada com a cidade do nosso
futuro e para quem essa cidade